Coffee Coolatta we are testing pumpkin
spice latte half a drink Starbucks when
I'm feeling bougie the next Starbucks
will make anything for you that you can
say whatever you want at the making I
don't understand what the pumpkin spice
is if you like bottled up like white
girls in Boots as a flavor it would be
pumpkin spice I am actually really
excited to try these visually it looks
very interesting
yeah visually this is wonderful it's
like ombre this looks like a candy corn
coffee
I hate candy corn yeah oh whoa this is
kind of good it kind of tastes like
cinnamon tea when you first sip it it
tastes like coffee but then it has that
like pumpkin spice aftertaste all I
taste is like caramel and sugar and milk
I'm a maybe I'm looking for one of the
rest I'm giving this two thumbs up
oh I don't like any coffee chocolate
chips I'm gonna give it a thumbs down
[Music]
this really looks like apple cider
[Music]
have we been tricked is there even any
pumpkin in this where's the pumpkin yeah
it's actually not that bad it just
tastes like a regular hot chocolate with
like a hint of pumpkin I like it a lot
it's a good mix yeah we both liked the
caramel apple spice yes I enjoyed the
caramel apple pumpkin spice nose I don't
think I would personally order it but if
offered one I would not turn it down the
ice one is good because it has coffee in
it but you can also still taste like the
pumpkin the hot chocolate was great
because it just tasted like hot choc
with a little kick a little spice to it
alright was a big judger of the pumpkin
spice latte after these hacks pretty
into it I'm like I can [ __ ] with some
pumpkin spice keep doing your thing
pumpkins where the drinks at when it
rings that when it drinks
[Music]